I'm Greg I'm chillin I'm grateful that
all of you have tuned into today's video
we're gonna watch the red band trailer
for bad mom's starring Kathryn Hahn and
one of my favorite leading actresses
she's pretty talented she's a great
actress that's what first drew me her
and then she is beautiful hot to look at
put the two together you got one
talented see how you really feel I am I
know
then why'd you bet I just wanted to make
sure that's what sure do yeah well
Kristen Bell yeah she's lethal weapon
that one you were so passionate about
Kristen Bell yeah I used to look up
those photos from her forgetting sarah
marshall where she was in the bikini
you know when movie first came out huh
man she was she was something precious
still is let's play this a red band
trailer so kids cover your ears and your
eye and your eyes let Susan so how much
was everything since no really when the
baby does so they're proposed wait
you see a roster because Steen Applegate
whoa today at five o'clock see you there
I'll totally get a sitter on a Tuesday
night okay super process the bank sing
no BPA no MSG the PHA no DHT no sesame
no soy and of course their nuts or eggs
or milk or butter or salt to sugar no
what's up
I'm so tired of trying to be this
perfect mom done everything I've ever
felt that big momma couldn't say don't
punish your kid don't say no to you can
damn hard trying to make our kids lives
of me
don't
I say we go punch that [__] right in the
tits
Wow
nice to get one name please never this
is my sexy bra looks like you wrapped an
ace bandage around some really touch it
is it hot oh my god it's like a mine
that when you put it in the fridge you
got a very voiceover ice ain't happening
oh she wasn't never he never gets fully
hard so I just have to count fold his
penis up like a balloon in Morris and
mission up inside me honey that sounds
horrible
sometimes I take the balls and shove him
up there too because at least you know
they're firm impossible to know whether
or not you're doing a good job my son so
watch his Sesame Street and he doesn't
get it
my son failed sale my daughter stole
away from a homeless woman I was I would
literally die for them right now
every time I think about that big dumb
[__]
that looks to like well I would love to
watch that movie I hope it is oh come on
man moms really know I love the idea
it's a great idea of like the you know
women taking their charge at the same
time you know it's like the moms the
moms never get the rolls like this this
is great no I love the idea I would love
to watch this film it sounds it looks
really funny too it does yeah it does
the only the only concerns I have for
any movie like this is like the same
concerns I have for any movie that
relies like on outlandish improv like
it's got to be funny or else it might
not be funny the craziness levels are
they seem like they pick up over the
course of the day it got a lot more
aggressive halfway through and then I
was like ah likes interesting with
neighbors to coming out or like you know
a bunch of woman are being real I hear
like they go all out in that film and
seeing this - oh yeah these women are
really committing to these yeah crazy
ass bits you know so it's like I really
like the caster like the combination of
everybody and I I certainly hope this
goes welcome so he was Kunis beautiful
and Kirsten Belle ha she's married a Dax
Shepard I know is that crazy
yeah I could have done in Kristen Bell
huh if Dax Shepard Kristen
Kathryn Hahn she's always a delight in
her crude ways really gonna them visit I
like German vivid yeah she was the mom
yeah she's the blonde she's playing like
she's been playing a lot of moms lately
oh yeah I mean she's you know maybe I
should stop yeah that's good there are a
lot of people get typecast as moms and
dining I think like female comedians are
like really on the rise right now it did
sort of start with bridesmaids when this
started happening more often and then
with like Tina Fey coming up and Amy
Poehler
now Amy Schumer and let broad city now
yes yes like so I'm sure there's more
than I haven't even mentioned yeah do
you know like to see these actresses
like leading a film like this and like
there's other people on board Jada
pinkett-smith usually does dramas
Christina Applegate you know I grew up
on watching Mary with children and I
loved her character she was oh God
was she hot whoa hey didn't tame myself
but y'all remember how hot she wasn't I
would like to see her go back to like
that kind of raunchy crude behavior and
like you know from like Mary with
children or even the sweetest thing like
that you know she's playing more of the
conservative one here you know yeah the
righteous one and I'm sure she'll be
great in it she's still pretty [__]
sexy and attractive they're all very
attractive woman I like funny woman I
didn't I would date a funny woman like a
really funny male female comedian and it
won't a funny woman you do yeah will
they make me laugh yeah he's like actual
funny woman are these like you know they
kiss today who like the items no no no
no no okay I only want to meet the
comedians okay nothing's hotter than
female comedian anyway guys yeah I'm
definitely gonna be there for bad moms
yeah he's what and I liked when they
split off from the hangover they did 21
and over yes like I like that better
than any of the subsequent hangovers
feel like they could get this thing
right you know they they could make a
splash is like you know hey we're on the
cutting edge too but I'm also worried
you know 21 and over and and the
hangover aren't perfect so you know if
they can nail this one I'd be really
psyched for them listen guys if you're
new to the channel you can subscribe
today become that reject
John yes reasons Jerry videos his in and
day gasps dubs a podcast that he hosts
on the real rejects I want you guys to
get John more respect he is the
co-founder of the real rejects
co-creator co-producer Co everything if
you guys don't start showing him your
look for all the gay subscribers he
would appreciate a dick pic no I don't
we talked about this you said you wanted
Francis and I don't we dig stuff and he
kind of picks it all from anybody the
outside world so you'd want to want a
dick pic no not a dick pic not any other
kind of pick don't open the last message
I sent you just delete it it's a picture
of Dan cyber stick